hello folks
welcome to rational science directly
from frankfurt germany
and today we have an exciting day we're
going to be talking about
plagiarism okay so let's get right to it
what is
plagiarism now here we have a
little uh definition you could say uh
fell
in the uh early 19th century do you find
it as
the highest form of flattery
love that you know a guy is form a
flattery is it flattery well let's find
out there's another opinion
and a fellow analyzer says you know
it's not really flattery and he gives
three reasons
for why plagiarism is not flattery here
they are
says uh plagiarism generally plague
plagiarist generally plagiarized because
they lack the skill
to create the work themselves
plagiarists try to find a work they can
think
they won't be likely to be caught with
and plagiarists rarely thoroughly read
and
understand the materials they grab
i think they they saw hit all three of
them right on the nose
i agree with all those three i think uh
that's what happens
when you plagiarize okay they don't read
they don't understand what they got
uh they don't think they're gonna be
caught and uh
and so you know they try to make usually
some money out of it
okay now uh you might say well bill
if i remember correctly you did some
plagiarism of your own
and you serve some time for it
[Laughter]
uh not really not quite see
mine was not really plagiarism and let's
discuss that for a second
and it's important it's an important
little detail okay let me put this up
here
okay and so what we have here
is uh first of all you have to dis
distinguish between
stealing and copying okay one of the
issues that
came out of my case okay
i was hit with a national stolen
properties act
a a stealing act
federal stealing act that involved
usually when people like you know bonnie
and clyde and john diligent
dillinger they would take you know rob a
car steal a car and they would take it
across state lines
and so they had to put the national
stolen properties act
to get to all this interstate stuff
okay that's why it became a federal
crime and you know uh
in the case of the national stolen
properties act it's only
valid if you steal from the government
from the u.s gun from the national
government the federal government
and uh you know i didn't qualify for
that but that's the
that's the only tool the prosecutors had
at their disposal
but more important than that is that
copying is not plagiarizing
not necessarily in fact it's not um
copying is plagiarizing if
you do if you do not give credit to the
originating party
in my case i did exactly the opposite
if i would have gone with what i copied
which is intel and amd processing
technology
i would have given that for example to
the cubans or to the chinese or the
iranians and just say look
uh you know i came up with all this
stuff in my garage
you know they wouldn't have given me
five cents they would have kicked me out
of the embassy
no no i in fact quite contrary i gave
proper credit to both amd and intel said
look this comes from amd and this comes
from intel
and that was really an error on my part
i
i repent to this day that i said that
because it didn't come from amd
or from intel you said what do you mean
wasn't that
technology amd's and intel's well that's
the next point you know
first you have distinguished what's
secret and what's in the public domain
and patents you know are in the public
domain
you have so much time so many years of
protection
for your patent and after that you know
anybody can use it and develop upon that
that's the way a patent works okay so
but if you keep it secret
uh nobody knows what to protect
and so you know it's not yours
if someone you know copies it and
distributes it
out there you're dead you're dead
because you didn't patent it
you have no protection the only way
you're going to get protection
is if you disclose it publicly
it's called a patent okay and
let me show you this
i was uh you know included in the
uh what is known as the industrial
espionage act of 1996.
senator orrin hatch of utah he uh
invoked my name
saying that you know that i had given
this stuff to china cuba and iran okay
and that i was prosecuted for it which
is another issue
that if you um
you know they don't do that with
copyrights you don't
you don't go to prison for copyrights
except me
but uh uh you get penalized in tort law
you know
under tort law you you have to pay with
your pocket
that's how they punish you okay
but uh the other issue is that um
intel and amd were not the owners and
again because they did not patent they
did not disclose
their uh processes
openly and so they had no protection
from the government
and that's why they had to create that
uh espionage act because
they wanted to protect protect some
called trade
secrets trade secrets what do you mean
trade secret you i mean a patent is
public not secret and if it's secret
what are you protecting
i mean it's like you you come up with
something in private
and you say it's my secret and i'm not
gonna disclose it to the world
it turns out you know someone uh close
to you
finds out about it and discloses it to
the world what recourse do you have
you know uh you didn't you didn't
disclose it to the world it's not yours
he took it from you so that's why
copyright law and patent law
are out there trademark law all these
laws are out there
to protect that that person who
discloses
his secrets to the world
that's the way it works okay and uh
imagine uh here borrowing and stealing
versus selling
there's an issue of jurisdiction also
from a legal standpoint i know all this
because i had to go through the whole
rigmarole okay
and uh it turns out that you borrow
okay you borrow the car from this friend
of yours and he says okay here's the
keys and he'll let you borrow the car
it turns out that you take the car from
new york
all the way to california and sell it
you made a buck on his
car and the question is
where do you get tried you should be
you'd be tried in new york because
that's where you
stole it although it was
a an issue of um borrowing
that turned into stealing later when you
sold the car
or should be you be tried in california
where you sold it
where was the crime committed and so you
get
all these little details in the law okay
and all this stuff applied in my
case and yeah uh
if you're wondering about good old
donald trump there that other fellow
there his name is diego suarez
i was asked by the cuban government to
turn him over to the cia which i did
and he's there with mr trump this is
1992.
okay and uh yeah you wonder about these
things okay he was there with
mr suarez who was turned over as a spy
working with uh
trumpet what mario lago and all that
other stuff okay whatever
okay uh so what are the advantages and
disadvantages of
uh trade secrets why did they put this
law
well here are the advantages trade
secret is not limited in time
okay you can keep prayer because it's a
secret right
continues and definitely as long as a
secret is not revealed to the public
it's a secret right uh whereas a patent
is only
in force for a specified time after
which others may freely copy the
invention
okay so those are the differences there
trade secret does not imply any
registration costs
has an immediate effect okay does not
require compliance with
any formalities it's a secret it's yours
okay it's just yours and does not
imply any disclosure of the invention to
the public
okay what are the disadvantages okay
here the disadvantages others may be
able to legally discover the secret
entitled to use it others may obtain
patent protection for
legally discovered secrets and the
secret
trade secret is more difficult to
enforce than a patent
okay so you can see what's happening
here yeah
um so you know
what happens here the big problem uh for
corporations like intel and amd
especially if you look at it from a
national security
point of view is that countries like
russia and china
you know if you go to the patent office
they go there as well and if it's public
they don't have to respect the 20-year
law and say well i'm going to wait 20
years before i do something with it
no they're going to implement directly
into their processes
and so here in this age of information
and disinformation
uh patent law had to change okay
because national security was at stake
and so
uh to this day you know you can't patent
stuff like uh
you know nuclear weapons and so on
because you know some
other country might might get the little
device and say oh oh they have
here at the u.s patent office let's go
over there and
quickly take snapshots of it you know so
that's why they have trade secret law
the other reason is that uh and i know
this
quite well because i worked in the
industry for many years
is that you know you you change the
specifications
at least i would say once a week
different specifications
so the process is continuously changing
okay and you can't just go to the patent
office every time you made a spec
change a process change and so that's
another
reason for not patenting uh processes
so patents uh are for certain devices
that you invent maybe you
you invented the red car instead of the
blue car so you go and patent the blue
car you know that sort of thing
uh trade secrets a little different
okay uh those have to be handled in a
different way and that's why the law
changed okay and yeah some people are
now getting 25 years
for violating trade secret laws
since that the
spying act of 1996 industrial spying
chinese especially because they take all
these secrets to china and china makes
advances thanks to
these the spying and that's sometimes
more important than military spying you
know if you
develop technology it's uh very
it goes very deep you know it
really can modify things substantially
within
a certain branch of industry
okay just in case i put something here
that
people like to see okay this is my oven
cam
i invented this okay so i put a
camera in my oven and i filmed fbi agent
john grant who passed away
and he was paying me and then uh the fbi
could not deny
that you know that uh i was uh
working with them okay what could they
say
and so i went after the fbi and the cia
and they went after my wife
and so i had to plea you know we both
had to sit at the table that prosecuted
me and
uh i had my hands in his nuts and he had
his hands in my nuts
and it was who squeezed first and so we
decided to reach that deal and i got
lenient terms and they didn't touch my
wife and that was the deal
and the fbi agents didn't go to prison
so
it was a good deal for everybody all
around okay and uh for those of you who
are interested also there's a
documentary on uh all that stuff
known as a crazy chair it's now it used
to be on netflix now it's on
amazon prime video okay so
you can look it up there and you'll find
it uh
pretty good movie spanish and english
and i guess it's
uh it's uh translated into both
languages
okay um so let's go back to this
issue here uh let's put this up here uh
we have a problem because uh with
plagiarism
because it has those those uh things
it's not flattery
you know these people try to get away
with something uh they don't really
understand what they took and uh you
know they don't think they're gonna be
caught
okay so uh and they don't have the
skills to develop
their own uh things these are the the
problems with
plagiarism okay so um
let me put this up here ah
okay uh so what happened well you know a
fellow
put a um a little thread in our
facebook page we have a page called
rational science
and he put uh this article there
and i looked at it and found out that
there was this fellow
his name is uh ricky mickey
callahan and he was there for a long
time
you know i never knew much about him
just
whenever he came in there and discussed
physics i would uh
talk to him usually confront him because
he had
uh weird ideas and so
people come in there and discuss physics
because that's what i'm interested in
okay and so uh this all came in there
and i wasn't aware that
for a couple years he had been
listening and reading and then taking
all that material
making his own website and
he took a lot of that material and
claimed it as his essentially
and that's what i'm going to go over now
okay and so
uh he does say in there uh he does admit
he says uh
you weren't supposed to see this and the
only reason i got to see it is because
there's this
site that he has known as demystifying
science
in facebook and some of the members in
our group
also belong to that group and one of
these members
he took this article and put it in our
group and that's the only reason i found
out about this fellow
otherwise you know i wouldn't have known
about him or what he was doing out there
had no idea he existed other than his uh
participation in our group okay
so he comes in there he puts that
article i started research and said well
who is this fellow
you know because i started looking at
some of his stuff
and found out they resembled very much
like stuff that i have out there
and so um i looked this guy up and uh
find out that he's uh published an
article
there's probably several articles uh in
business insider
and that's what they say and this gives
you
a an overall picture of what this guy is
up to
him and this lady we're a couple
who was furloughed from our jobs so
we're using the time in self-isolation
to turn our passion project
into a viable business here's how we're
making it happen
okay and the lady uh anastasia
bendisbury and
fellas michael shilo delay they go by
those
uh monitors those also known as
uh she's gonna be nasty and he's gonna
be shiloh
okay we have nasty and shiloh nasty
shiloh
well if he's shiloh i mean i think uh
his grandfather must have been in
the civil war or something or he's
shiloh i'm
bull run okay he's gonna come up against
manassas junction that's what's gonna
happen here
and they say that together they run the
demystifying science site
okay what is this all about says we put
our heads together and came up with
strategies for getting
published and getting paid it's about
money
it worked in the first month 17
000 people read our work and they
published that in april 16
2020 almost a year uh
to the day today okay uh so
uh they're they publish their stuff
which is good i like uh
young people to go out there and publish
stuff no problem
uh but as you can see they publish uh
girly stuff you know testimonials that
sort of thing
and you know a lot of people buy that
most people buy that in fact
they're not into science you know people
out there they want to read
testimonials how to make money and that
sort of thing and that's what these
people publish
okay fine no problem uh i congratulate
you
uh but
on the other side give me a second here
oh sometimes falls on the other side of
the wall here with
my program and so you look them up and
you find this demystifying science in
facebook
okay about this group this group history
says they were created in 2017
and it had originally apparently was the
art of rational science
which is what we had we didn't call it
the art of rational science we called it
uh i think the rational scientific
method maybe
at some point we called it rational
science then they changed the name to
the art of explanation
and finally they left it as a mystifying
science
okay so uh that was a more or less the
history of the group it's got 5 000
followers
comparison to our group we have like 80
or 90 followers we
we have very few he's this fall and this
lady
they have a lot okay or a lot more than
us you know
okay um what concerned me when i looked
up
this fella when he looked i looked at
his website their website and i guess
they're a couple and they work together
and
this is what offended me offended me
from this time
this has offended me tremendously they
uh
invoke people who are mathematical
physicists
so here they're i'm gonna look at their
website they're gonna i'm gonna find a
lot of my stuff
i don't see my name anywhere and instead
i see
references to people in mathematical
physics which they apparently
you know look up to and here's the first
one his name was david lindley
okay or is david lindley and who is this
fellow
well this fellow is a censor that's what
his job was all his
all his life what he did was he worked
for
some of these magazines these journals
and uh but he did all his life with
censor people
and this guy you know he claims oh it's
the end of physics this was an article
written in i think the new york times
and what does he talk about well he
talks about verifying by experiment
uh talking about such theories
as big bang are plausible
okay he says that mathematics is the
language of physics
he believes in the standard model why
because he it's based on experiments
and he says that the standard model
explains what has been revealed by
experiment
absolutely not uh mathematical physics
in its entirety doesn't explain anything
all they have are descriptions in fact
they consider explanations outside
the bounds of science they consider that
philosophy
and so when you try to publish something
in one of these science magazines that
this fellow ran he was the director or
editor
in chief or something uh they censor you
they say look uh we don't want to hear
that quantum is irrational
we know it's irrational we don't
understand it we're like
richard feynman said he said no one
understands quantum mechanics and so
they don't care about
physical interpretations they don't
consider that science they consider that
philosophy
and so you can't publish a different
version of how this universe works
especially at the micro
level in the case of quantum macro level
in the case of
relativity you can't publish anything
along those lines they will only allow
you to publish
equations and so when you go to these
uh so-called uh so-called
science literature you will never find a
picture
what you'll find is equations so you
won't find mechanisms of how this
universe work you won't find a mechanism
for gravity you won't find a mechanism
for light you won't find a mechanism
for magnetism or electricity you won't
find a mechanism for any of that stuff
why because all you want to see is
equations descriptions quantitative
descriptions
and so yeah it's impossible to publish
something in one of those magazines
if you don't publish there the blogs
won't read it
won't translate it for the masses and
nobody hears about your theory
so it's uh it's a way of
doing shadow banning you can talk all
your life as long as you talk to the
ocean to the wall
you know but they're not going to allow
the public
to listen to you and that's the issue
okay so
this guy's just a sensor he's part of
the establishment and these people put
him in the in fact interviewed him uh in
one of their uh
podcasts okay and they uh also glorify
this lady
which i talked about a couple weeks ago
her name is
uh sabine hassenfelder she works here a
couple miles north of where i live
and uh she defected they say
she defected from the mathematical
physics camp
absolutely not she's a mathematical
physicist
uh 150 percent she does
what does he do she does uh what is it
dark angels dark spirits he does dark
matter and dark
uh energy that's what she works on
that's what a group does
and what is dark energy well dark energy
is you know you have this big bang
explosion so you have to believe in big
bang to begin with
if you're going to do this kind of stuff
they're saying that there was this
explosion everything's running away from
ground zero
and they said well why doesn't gravity
pull it back in and they say well it's
this dark
energy these dark angels that are
pushing everything outwards
and that's what she studies she's
looking for dark energy and dark matter
so no she hasn't abandoned mathematical
physics
at all okay so let's make that clear and
i made that clear and
you look up the video i have a video on
her okay
exposes the confusion of math viz in her
book
lost in math well again it's like this
other guy lindley you know they say oh
you know we we say we talk against math
uh against these mathematicians
they talk against and then they
immediately propose the same thing
they propose you know what do they
propose they propose
quantum mechanics and general relativity
so so we're back to square one they're
just going around in circles saying we
criticize them to sell books and then
they come back and say oh but we do
mathematical physics as well
so i don't know what they're criticizing
no these people are
completely within the tampa mathematical
physics which is total irrationality
irrational explanations 150 percent of
it
and they say that she alleges particles
are measurements
well yeah but she deals with particles
because to this day after 10
000 years no one has invented anything
other than particles
except me i have come up with something
different than particles i'm the only
person
on planet earth okay so let's get that
straight
okay and so uh she still believes in
particles and vouchers for qm for
quantum mechanics
and her group again researches dark
matter and dark energy
and she says this is a statement from
hers okay it says dark energy and dark
matter are entirely normal
and perfectly scientific hypothesis
no they're not because like uh
mr feynman said there is they don't know
what energy is to begin with
and energy is a concept and you can't
say that a concept
pushes against gravity which is another
concept you need to identify what the
physical mediators are
if you're going to talk about what's
pushing that out what's pulling that in
okay if you're going to talk about
gravity you got to identify the physical
mediators that pull on things yeah
because
that's what they're saying you know it's
it's push against
pull and the pull is known as gravity
and the push is known
as dark energy and you know when
whenever you push a box
you have to use your hands or something
maybe a horse or some mediator some
physical meteor
whenever you pull on a donkey you gotta
have a mediator physical mediator
and what these people don't have is
physical mediators why because they're
mathematicians they are not physicists
so that mathematical physics
physicist thing the physicist is too
much it's
uh false advertising that's what it
amounts to
okay um and in their site these uh
these uh demystifiers okay
they uh also mention this follow my
earn and they
they put a question there and say what
causes inertia
okay and says mach discovered the
explanation to inertia
well did he i mean what's the
explanation
in other words what's the physical
interpretation
for a physical interpretation you need
objects
and you know mach was not smart enough
to figure out what objects were doing
the
pulling and the issue is that mark's
principle says that you know all the
stars essentially pulling on you
something discovered really by newton
because you have newton's bucket
where you drill a bucket that's hanging
from a little
rope and if you twirl it with having
water right
and the water will go up the the sides
and so the question is why does it
what's pulling on that water
and so newton himself realized that's
something outside of the earth
you're pulling against something you're
like when a skater rotates way to their
arms go outwards well because you're
being pulled by the stars how can the
stars
pull on you if they're so far away well
maybe you're connected
physically connected to the stars maybe
that's the answer
and of course ernest marx had a notion
in the intuition that
we were pulling against the stars but he
says i don't see anything between my
fingers and the stars
and that goes to these this observation
issue that we've been discussing lately
yeah you cannot observe that which is
invisible and intangible you can't
run an experiment to elucidate
what is invisible and intangible the
only way to approach that
is through thinking you do a thought
experiment you
visualize and try to imagine how mother
nature could be doing this
with physical objects that are
intangible
and invisible that's how you do it so
mike never discovered that
in fact you look at the wikipedia and
has this note in there
uh about ma he just said it like you
know in passing it's not like he
wrote a paper on it or anything he says
one of the best known of mock's
ideas is the so-called mock principle
concerning the physical
origin of inertia this was never
written down by mach he never wrote this
down
but was given a graphic verbal form
attributed to philip frank
to mock himself as when the subway jerks
it's the fixed stars that throw you down
there you have the synthesis of mock's
principle
and the guy who made mock famous on this
issue was einstein
because he used the same notion he says
you know we're being pulled by the stars
and then he came up with space time and
all this other stuff that
all the mathematicians in those days
were just discussing
in their meetings and so on and
so they continue in their site in the
mystifying science uh they say
the only explanation for gravity is that
all atoms
are pulling on you okay but see
they didn't attribute that to me they
attributed to
ma they say he came up with the
explanation now the explanation is when
you put a physical object in there
when you have interconnectedness
and until you have physical
interconnectedness you cannot talk about
pull of any kind okay so
it's interesting that these folks gave
credit to
uh hassan felder and to linden to uh ma
and probably to other people in their
site you know
but they didn't mention me at all you
know um
big old mission okay okay
so i go to shiloh's
page that struck me you know because
uh he says that you need
objects to do physics and they have to
be objects that exist because physics
apparently has something to do with
objects and with existence
and so they go in there and they have a
page where they analyze these two words
okay and this is what they say okay says
what does it mean for something to exist
in physics
uh-huh well that's a subject right down
my alley
so the word exists is central to many if
not all scientific discussions
yet is almost never defined
unambiguously and then utilized in such
a consistent fashion
i'm going to make the case i
he's going to make the case i see thank
god someone did
okay that this confusion is central to
the apparent stagnation of theoretical
physics
and hence at the heart of modern
scientific conversations
failure to establish a unified physical
picture of our universe
all words and hence all ideas regardless
of the language can be divided into one
of
two categories object and concept now
where could he have gotten that
and says an existing object is a body
with location
and uh what is that body is that is
something with a shape
okay so uh you know i heard of of all
this before i wonder where he got all
this
okay and it says a concept on the other
hand is merely a relationship between
what
one existing object and another or an
additional concept
i wonder where he got the notion of
concept why would he talk about concept
in the in in the context of this
conversation okay
and physics on the other hand
necessarily begins with existing
objects we als we start with such an
object in physics because it is the
science that principally deals
with the dynamics of existing bodies
in order for that object to exist it has
to also have
location and defines that as a set of
static distances to all other objects in
the scene
without a location an object cannot be
said to exist
man i could swear i heard that somewhere
where did i heard hear of that before
and yeah good old mickey callahan which
is the other name for
shiloh here uh he was in our group for a
long time
two or three years i i don't know how
long he was in there but i know he's
been there for a long time because
he would come in their debate you know
and talk physics but i didn't know what
he was doing in
in secret back there okay and so let's
see
where he got this stuff let's see if uh
this rings a bell
this is in my site you stupid
relativist.com
it says summary of principles
foundations and definitions of science
and physics
so physics is first and foremost the
study of objects you cannot do physics
without an
object an object is that which has shape
and space is that which doesn't
a concept is a word that embodies or
invokes two or more objects a concept is
a relation between objects
thus the definition of the word object
precedes the definition of the word
concept
we refer to the space separating the
surfaces of any two objects as
distance the distance of physics is not
the same as the distance traveled of
mathematics
something that shiloh did not understand
obviously because you got to spend two
years on the word distance
and he didn't even cover that he just
copied and pasted you know
location consists of the set of
distances from one object to the
remaining ones in the
system and physics only studies objects
that exist physics is a science of
existence
exists is a word circumscribed to
objects
okay so uh looks like uh
mr shiloh and miss nasty uh
they just went to my site or maybe to
the facebook uh
area i don't know uh and got all this
stuff from there and they just reworded
it a little bit and put it in there
because they
covered the word exist object location
distance which this guy because he
copied paste
and pasted didn't realize it was an
important word to analyze in
much more detail than what he did he
says oh this you know with distance
yeah okay and he just copied and pasted
it
and so yeah you need to define he's
wearing also the word concept for that
matter
so you know all these words they were
taken out of my site
and in that page he did not give me
credit at all
okay completely without credit he just
took it and put it in his
and that's a very important part because
this is what i always say and uh i keep
saying it over and over again
apparently this fella never listened
okay the definition of the word object
destroys
all religion my most important
contribution to science and of which i'm
most proud of
was not the rope hypothesis it was the
definition of the word
object and realizing that you can't do
physics without it
see we have euclid and he defined
a figure essentially an object because
it's a synonym of the word object
as not that which has shape he says that
which has boundary
and then when you look at boundary you
say well that's what surrounds a shape
so he was trying to find the word shape
he couldn't get around as he just put
those two statesmen
statement in there but they were close
enough i mean to say you know an object
is that which has shape
an object is that which has a boundary
he was on the right track
the problem with euclid is but two
problems the first one is he never used
that
definition because in all of geometry
you will not find a
shape you will not find a figure
as i discussed in the last couple weeks
what you will find is
itineraries you'll find lines made of
locations
those are itineraries and all of
geometry is
measurement it's a dynamic discipline
it's not a static discipline where
you have the figures the geometric
figures there
and so what's the problem is that the
figure belongs to
physics and the ridiculous nonsense that
the mathematicians do
has to do with itineraries so they're
describing itineraries because they deal
with measurements they deal with
units and so we can't
we can't merge those two you can't merge
the itineraries with the figures
these are two different things physics
deals with the figures
and math deals with itineraries
okay and i have that statement the
reason atheist theists in agnosis have
debated in circles about the existence
of god for hundreds of years
is that they never define the word exist
so i'm the owner of the word
object i'm the owner of the word exist
once you invent the wheel once you
invent fire
you can't have another person reinvented
it's just as simple as that and
so this guy just copied paste it says oh
i'll call it mine
okay he didn't give me credit he gives
credit to all these other people
who are mathematical physicists doesn't
even mention
me and his site okay um
so uh i go and look at his uh
adam his magnetism his electricity
his light see what he's gonna talk about
i mean what is he gonna put on his site
well i found a lot of stuff that seemed
very familiar to me
okay and here's the first one he puts
his atom in there and he's got these
little uh
wires he calls him fibers tails
filaments he uses words like that he
does not use the word
thread he does not use the word rope
okay and uh but that's what he's going
to illustrate
and he's going to call it something else
because he says well
you know like you know you look at a
rope and it's got these links
okay each one of those uh red and blue
uh
sets we call them links links of a rope
but when you have a chain well
the the uh the links are you know
they're separated each link is a
separate issue
a separate entity and so he thinks he
invented something because he put a
chain instead of a rope so he said i got
something different than you bill
i don't have a rope i have a chain okay
and that's more or less what the problem
is going to be here the issue's not
what he's going to do what he's going to
use his chain or
or the rope with the issue is the
mechanism
okay the issue's going to be the
mechanism so this fella puts all these
little lines there and you wonder what
all these little tails and filaments and
fibers that he mentions there
are and you'll never find them
you know he doesn't really give you an
idea what those
are but he does in um
well first let me put this up here which
is uh just so that you can
compare against mine okay that's my atom
okay and that was made by a follower by
the name of dave and i gave him full
credit
my book which is downloadable for free
okay known as the rope hypothesis and
that's the 2d version
another fellow known by the name of dan
i won't give their names you can find
them in the
the in the uh book okay and
he made this three the uh version i gave
them both
credit okay total credit and i really do
thank them for it
um okay and uh
and so the question is what are those
lines that this follow is uh
is putting up there you know what are
those little lines
see i'm looking at the proton what his
proton looks like and mine you can see
are the convergence of threads it's a
star
and his looks like a little mess there
that you know a little tangle
it's very hard to understand this is not
his picture this is a picture i got
somewhere else because of legal issues
that are underway and so um
i didn't want to put his model there uh
exactly uh for different reasons
anyways the issue here is that uh
he doesn't define what the he doesn't
identify what these little threads are
what his proton looks like what a
neutron looks like you know
maybe he will in the future if he gets a
chance
we'll find out about that but uh
so here is what he puts for the mediator
of light
okay and so what is light speed why
is light speed limited okay and of
course he's going to use
my notion of you know
the fact that the more links you have
the
the uh shorter each link that sort of
thing
uh says the photon is merely a wave of
deformation
of some existing structure that spans
the distance between the emitting and
receiving atoms
sounds a lot like my rope model you know
you have two atoms
and a rope in between okay what is the
structure the shape of the mediator of
light and gravity
yeah what is the mediator of light and
gravity hopefully it's a physical entity
okay whatever it is is a physical entity
and there's only two possibilities in
the universe
one is you send discrete particles
or a wave made of particles one way
which is what everybody's done in the
last ten thousand years everyone
and then you have what bill gates came
up with and that's
interconnectedness and there's no
in between there's no gray you know you
don't have maybe here
it's one or the other you know you
either
do it with discrete particles and you
shoot them on do push
and maybe do pull through pressure that
sort of thing
you know uh casimir type effects and uh
or
you do pull with an elongated
entity a mediator and that's where the
problem's going to be because this guy
is going to copy
the mechanism which is
you know some physical object
interconnecting to
atoms that's where the
plagiarism comes into play seems
absolutely necessary to explain light
and gravity in terms of deformable what
mediating material between the terminal
atoms
now who came up with that did he come up
with that
material between uh the terminals of
atoms and it turns out that
you know that he says that
an object would is that which has shape
but this is what this fellow
comes up with next he says that
light is not an object
and this is what he proposes i guess uh
these uh little links i guess i don't
know what you call them i guess i'll
call them links for lack of a better
word
and but he says the fabric of existence
clearly has the shape of atoms
and the innumerous interconnection
between them
interconnections where did he get
interconnections
that there's a physical entity
interconnecting atoms
where do you get this notion mechanism
by which it deforms rearrangement of
hook loop subunits okay so he created
those links
he thinks that's uh different okay it is
a little different yeah for sure i'm not
going to take
i'm not going to take credit for that
for sure
light isn't an object he says
light isn't an object what is he showing
there it looks like you know he's going
to say that these
links are physical things that unite to
adam but he says it's not an object
okay that's kind of strange kind of
inconsistent right it is a torsional
perturbance of the fabric of existence
fabric of existence what the world
in the world is he talking about what
physical object is this
fabric of existence oh it's true he said
it's not an object
okay my mistake so here we have two
atoms they're bound to each other he's
going to explain gravity and
magnetism and light with us
he says they're bound but they're not
bound or they're bound by what by a
concept
known as the fabric of existence
fabric of existence it says this fabric
is an elastic web web
that is comprised of hoop look uh
fibrous atoms and their interconnections
okay so what is he talking about um
maybe he's talking about this
maybe this is what he's referring to we
have brian green he talks about the
fabric of the cosmos
and einstein talked about the fabric of
space-time is that what the fabric that
he's talking about
and look it up it says fabric and cloth
and material are synonyms of
textile a textile is any material made
of the interlacing fibers a fabric is a
material made through
weaving knitting spreading felting
stitching
crocheting crocheting and bonding
okay so um what material is this that
he's talking about this uh
fabric of existence is it uh what is it
uh
yarn what are we talking about here what
is that
fabric i had that talk with in uh
what's his name uh jf
uh garippi uh canadian fellow who runs
uh his
site in youtube and they had this uh
mathematical physicist come in there and
ask them what's between the electron
and the proton in a hydrogen atom
and he said it's the fabric the fabric
that's uh and like this guy says it's
like saying um
what is this stuff what's the furniture
of existence what do you mean the
furniture of existence
i mean you're talking about a chair
you're talking about what kind of
furniture are you talking about
and this is more or less the same thing
he's saying the fabric what fabric i
mean nylon
what fabric are you talking about what
is this fabric
and of course fabric of existence is a
concept
and he's going to be pulling two atoms
together and doing stuff with
fabrics okay so on the one hand he
uh he takes my mechanism which is the
issue what's it an issue here
takes my mechanism and which is
interconnectedness and he puts his own
stuff say well
but i do it differently i do with little
links i don't care how you do it
interconnectedness belongs to me okay
i invented i came up with
interconnectedness
sorry you can't invent the wheel you
can't invent fire again
you can't say yours is green fire
okay uh fire is fire okay and so
we either have interconnectedness or we
have what mathematical physicists
have been proposing for 10 000 years now
which is
particles discrete particles pushing so
you can't have both
it's one or the other and there's no
intermediate
but if you can come up with an
intermediate that does not involve
pulling through some physical mediator
hey then i'd like to see it because i
don't know what you could
have come up with so this is the issue
the issue's mechanism here
that's what he's uh borrowing
without authorization okay and uh so
just uh
mentioning here you can see it there his
mechanism
pumping and it turns out that he changes
the
the wording he doesn't call it pumping
he calls it um what was it
breathing it says the atoms are
breathing
and by breathing obviously they're going
to torque the rope because you're going
to talk about torsion
okay so uh yeah uh
it's quite uh my uh my
uh what is it uh
my model for mechanisms
which is what's the important part and
here is uh what he's showing for more or
less
okay this is my model but this is what
he's going to
show for electricity he's saying it's
torsion of
merged electron shells where did he get
merged electron shells if the standard
model just
mentions that in passing like saying
well yeah the
shells but the shells are just orbitals
and the orbitals are just regions where
you can find the electron
bead and this guy turns them into
physical objects which is
where he got that from me he says uh
there are membranes
he's going to merge these membranes and
then he's going to twirl them around
like i did there and say that
electricity
is the torsion of all these merged
shells okay so again
uh you borrow that uh i guess from my
site
okay and then and or from facebook you
know the
rational science rational scientific
method site
okay and uh so how does he do attraction
magnetic attraction well he does it this
way
which is you know you have all these
threads moving around
if they move in the same direction well
they interlock and they pull
to pull the two wires together and
that's essentially what he's explaining
except that he's going to say well i do
it with these little
wires or whatever he's got there uh
that he puts in by hand you know we
don't know what these wires are what
this
um fabric of existence that's twirling
around is
he says that the electron shells are
fuzzy and they extend to infinity
you know a bunch of nonsense but the
mechanism is the issue
the issue is that when you have this
mechanism it goes like that that's
that produces pull and that's what he's
copied and what does he do
for uh repulsion oh he does this
puts this up there essentially okay this
is the repulsion
if you have one going clockwise the
other one going counterclockwise
the threads now they push each other
away and that's my mechanism
which is the important part and he does
it with these little
wires these little um
i don't know what they are for lack of a
better word i'll call him uh what
uh fabric of existence he's got the
fabric of existence
twirling around you know all over the
place but he says they're objects
that which they aren't objects you know
they're objects but they're not objects
you know light is mediated
not mediated by an object he says it's
just it just pulls two atoms together
by concepts i guess
so here's the only two possibilities
okay
you either do math fizz discrete
particles or you do the rope model
interconnected atoms that's it there's
no
third possibility and what he and this
fellow
apparently he studied physics or biology
at the university of columbia supposedly
got a phd
even though he doesn't seem to be able
to know how to reference
you know you would think that a guy who
studied physics
at that level at the phd level would at
least know how to reference
um things you know uh give proper credit
he doesn't do that he just uh completely
bypassed the references
and he does he should if he studied you
know either physics
or biology well he should have learned
that model there in fact he taught
physics at the high school level
and so he should have taught
the mathematical physics the discrete
particles version
so where did he get the rope model the
one where we have interconnectedness
whether he does it with little links or
or little uh wet
fabrics of existences or whatever it
doesn't matter but
he's talking about interconnectedness
that's where he commits his
plagiarism especially when he doesn't
give any credit whatsoever
okay and um so one fellow
put the real reason that uh this
demystifying science
group is up there and it's for this he
says
he made a kind of said i think the
demystifying science audience
are more concerned about trying to
acquire your credit card details
yeah totally in agreement uh this guy's
not into science he's into business
okay it's not like me i have a passion
for physics
i have a tremendous passion for these
things uh
you know i don't do things for money
that's the difference between me and
so many other people out there you say
well bill don't you have a patreon page
uh yeah the patreon page you know first
of all i don't think i can live two days
with what i get from patreon you know
patreon
page i put it up there so it's a token
it's a token of your appreciation to
keep the program alive that's all it's
for
i wanted to leave it to you know to 10
cents but
patreon wouldn't wouldn't allow me you
know you know they said
the minimum is one dollar so that's what
i put up there and it's interesting that
when i created my patreon page
they one of the things that you got to
answer is
when do you think you reached your goal
you know
some people say well i want to make a
thousand bucks per month two thousand
three thousand whatever you know
and i put it there immediately i said uh
uh i've already reached my goal one
person gave me one dollar
and that was my goal as long as i have
one dollar i'm going to keep the
program running and i have generous
people there who give a little more than
the dollar and thank them
and again it's all just appreciation
just to keep the program
running so that we have a discussion in
physics
not even money these folks
nasty and uh shiloh you know
they're into money they're into
something else they're living off of
this
okay so this is a little different okay
and
yeah a lot of people fall because for it
because they see some of this flashy
stuff
and they say oh i like that they don't
even know what they're staring at
they don't know what questions to ask
and that's what this channel is for here
we we get to the bottom of things
believe me and we don't skirt
questions you can put whatever questions
you want in my site you can cuss my
mother if you want i don't care
you want to come here we'll discuss
physics that's what this site is for
and i have a passion for physics just
like one time i had a passion for
communism
and that passion faded away and i had a
passion
for atheism and that faded away as well
but i don't think this one's gonna fade
away i think i'm gonna die with a rope
model
and i have a passion for physics so this
site is not about making money this site
is about physics about real science
if you know you don't like my theory
fine come and debate me
fight me insult me love it okay
that's what this site is about these
people are into something else they're
in
they're creating a uh a corporation or a
sole proprietorship whatever
okay so it turns out that
uh this fellow or lady i don't know
one of the two i guess it's the fellow
uh went in there and
made some changes to the site today or
yesterday night i don't know
and he put these these changes to some
of his pages
okay because i wrote him a letter and i
said uh i think you got some stuff that
belongs to me
on your site and he says
he answers no i don't but if you can
find
something that in in the literature out
there that i published
uh that belongs to you or i guess in his
site
he would gladly correct it and he went
in there and corrected these on his own
okay well unfortunately it's a little
too little
too late and he's been running with us
for two and a half years i think or
three years
behind my back uh putting his stuff in
his sight
creating his uh his little empire there
and he changed the names of things he
could have called them threads he could
have called them
uh robes whatever no credit
he never used those words he changed the
the same concept he just
called them wires uh
what was it the fabric of existence you
know he gave them all these fancy names
and again not knowing the difference
between an object and a concept
but even worse he's he uh
he put these like saying oh i fixed the
problem see i put your name in there
in in my site and at least four of these
sites well
the problem here is he uh he he doesn't
know how to give credit
he doesn't know i mean suppose he's a
phd right and
you would think that a guy like that
would at least have learned the basics
of
of how to give proper credit and he
doesn't he dilutes it he says look i
give credit to all these people and my
mother and my grandfather my
great-granddaddy who fought at shiloh
okay
and you know uh he he puts a whole bunch
of people in there like i owe it to all
of these people
no no no uh the word object belongs to
me
the word exists belongs to me i was the
one who defined those
and the rope model interconnectedness in
other words
belongs to me and pull belongs to me
because there is no pull in mathematical
physics
just like the um what is it the
uh theory of extinction mass extinction
in the past belongs to me
the overturning of the population
pyramid belongs to me
okay i have a lot of stuff that belongs
to me because i put them
in a book which i published in 1998
this is the second
version of it it came out in the year
2000
okay and i have uh this is my
registration for it
uh see if i can put it here okay and
register a certificate of registration
okay that it's registered uh
in the united states okay and i changed
that color to black because
i became a racist against white people
you know
and so i changed it from white to black
and so now the cover is is black
but and that's the fourth edition there
that's the one that's out there now
and uh that's been out there since the
year 2008.
so i've had this stuff on you know on
out there for a long time now
20 years okay it's been out there and so
what's the issue the issue is
he gives credit to a whole bunch of
people like saying well i put you in
there with with this whole group
and he mentions fat fist who was one of
the first people
to buy my book unfortunately he's not
no longer around these days um
and padfist uh you know he he
took some of my stuff and put it in uh
hub pages hub pages is a site also where
you can
you know put things in there you know
write write things
and uh fatfist he went in there he asked
me for
some of the stuff because he had a
debate with some atheist out there
i don't really know the details and so
he used a lot of my material he used uh
especially
the word life you know i'm gonna get to
that in a second
uh and and so you know he he mentioned
fat fist like you know i got this from
all these other sources
well fat fist is not a um a
formal source you know fat fist did not
write when he was alive you know he did
not
write even i publish anything
so it's like an informal source and
again he got it all from me he got it
from why god doesn't exist from from my
book
that's how fat fits got it i mean again
he's one of the first guys to buy my
book
and so i thank him for that too
okay so he diluted it and then he says
well you know but this is not
bill gates real model uh
again too little too late first of all
he he blindsided me for two years or so
and then he comes at the last moment and
says oh by the way yeah bill gates gave
me some ideas about this
no no he took the mechanisms outright
you either have push or you have pull
and what mathematical physics doesn't
have is pull
because you need a physical mediator and
that's what he took away
he took the this and claimed it as his
claim does his because he didn't give me
credit for two and a half years until i
discovered him now he said oh by the way
bill see i gave you credit
[Laughter]
or val i mean he he doesn't know
anything about tort law obviously
i recommend that he check real quick
with a lawyer
consult him you know learn a little bit
about tort law
anyways what is interesting is uh it's
about shiloh and this lady
nasty they uh put in one of their uh
videos they say please share your ideas
on how to improve the model further
okay so i went in there to try to share
some ideas you know with them in fact
that wasn't the only one apparently
there was another fellow
and uh and this fella went in there and
he put a comment
a couple comments in fact he put in
there a comment he says
you copy bill gates model which i've
shown has several limitations and
is irrational you copied bill gates
irrational rope model
yes uh very easy to see that he did
light is thus
imagined as a discrete torsional
deformation of the thin
elastic tails tails that's what he calls
them
of atomic e shells in that each photon
is a singular event with a specific
strength or energy
it says really you copy bill gates
rope hypothesis.com have you thought how
long this tale is
to reach us from the furthest reaches
and he goes
and so i put a note there myself and i
said thank you paul
i don't know who he is says whether you
believe or not in the role
model or think that it is irrational
that part of your argument is immaterial
to the instant context
like everyone else you recognize that
what's in this site was plagiarized from
the rope hypothesis beginning with the
definitions of object exist
at l but he but be aware that mickey and
quinn
that's uh shiloh nasty there you know
delete comments as well
and that's exactly what i predicted in
fact they've been deleting
comments not only in their site but in
youtube
and so they're asking for contributions
to
please help us you know with con
with uh suggestions on how we can
improve the model well we're trying to
get in contact with them but they're
deleting the comments
and i predicted that that's exactly what
he would do that's why i put the
comments i put the comments because i
want to see if he erases them he did
yeah he's uh one of these
people who hides which another you know
not only did he
try to hide the model that he invented
you know for two and a half years until
finally giving me credit and you wonder
i mean if if that's not his material why
is he
giving me credit why did he decide in
april 11 or maybe april 10 to
give me credit if i don't deserve the
credit
if you say well yeah bill gates gave me
some ideas there you know
um yeah
[Laughter]
i mean he shouldn't give me credit if
it's not mine right he should not say
give me credit at all and if he's gonna
give me credit he better give me credit
in the right way and not the way he did
it
like saying well i got i got all these
ideas from faraday and my grandmother
and you know
yeah that's not the way to give credit
so it's too little too late he's been
hiding all this stuff uh
and trying to build a business with it
that's that's
what he's all about him and his uh lady
friend there
what do they call them they call them to
these days partners
my partner they say you know it's in
uh incidentally you know uh you know how
you know if you're married
because i define that as well no one has
ever defined the word marriage except me
so listen carefully before they
these two fellows steal that from me as
well how do you know you're married
okay and i i have a little experience
i've been married 45 years
with the same woman love her you know
she's great
and uh how do you know if you're married
is it because you love her
like i love my wife uh is it because uh
um you know you have a certificate that
says i went before the judge and swore
that
you know forever and ever no
so listen carefully i'm going to give
you the definition of marriage
okay you heard it here first of all
marriage is equal to
one bank account
that's the definition of marriage one
bank
account if the two of you whether
it's uh this diversity thing of today
or it's he and she and she and him him
are married or not is determined by
whether you have one
bank account if you have two bank
accounts
i don't care what the certificate says i
don't care what the judge says you're
not
married and i'll let you do as homework
uh figure out why that's the case okay
so
i've been married 45 years we've had
one bank account okay so that's the
definition of marriage
okay um
what do i have here
oh yeah here's a summary then of uh
what the problem is okay of what these
people
why these people are at fault uh they
blindsided me for two and a half years
two years at least
about using my material okay i had no
idea these people were doing this behind
my back i just found out because of this
threat that this fellow happened to put
in the
this site and this fellow his name uh
mickey callahan that's his moniker he
comes in and says oh it was put in here
by mistake
no kid what an error it's like you steal
from the bank and you put it in the bank
and they say
hey all these bills are marked oh
i wasn't supposed to put it in the bank
my wife made that error
yeah okay they deliberately change the
language they don't use the word thread
and rope so they wouldn't be detected
they use these other words okay so you
know
i never picked up on that nowhere on the
uh this
demystifying science site is my name
reference despite that there were many
references to other individuals okay uh
they just put the references today
or yesterday night i don't know and uh
why did it put my name in there if uh if
i don't deserve the credit if i deserve
the credit why
put me in there with faraday and with
all these in
fat fist and his grandmother and who
knows what who else
i mean you know is that the way to give
credit say i got it from all these
people
i got it through my upgrades from my
professor and i owe my
unless he gave me a speech on why you
got a nobel prize
what is this and um
outright plagiarize the relevant
mechanisms that's what he plagiarized
and these are just some of them i only
included four in here
emergency electron shells that spin in
situ to produce electricity
okay what i call my serpentines he uh
the parallel live wires attract and
repel due to
physical mediators extending from atoms
icon threads
he diluted then gave him a different
name
light consists of a torsion of a
dna-like rope-like mediator
well it's a mediator it's a physical
mediator and that's what he's putting in
there but he's saying well it's a fabric
of existence that's in there
so again he doesn't understand the word
object why because he copied and pasted
whatever he saw there he said oh this
sounds nice and he put it in there he
doesn't understand the word object to
the state
he doesn't know the difference between
an object and a concept
and then obviously he's going to use
that not only for gravity but
the you know he's got the equation of a
rope essentially there he put that one
over lambda
okay um
let's see if i i think it's this one
okay so these are the things that belong
to me
okay this is out of why god doesn't
exist
okay book the book there
ah there we go my god doesn't exist okay
that's the book and 500 page book broke
my head on that one
it was uh it ended up being 500 pages
originally it was 2
500 pages five times as big i had to cut
so much stuff
in there because i write a lot read a
lot do a lot of research
anyways no one in the last 10 000 years
has defined
the word object that's my number one
thing i'm proud of i define the word out
that word belongs to me and no one else
okay or realize that physics demands an
object you give a physical
interpretation which is what science is
about which is what physics is about
you're going to give an explanation
of a mechanism you need objects sorry
and no one ever figured that out never
even realized that you have all these
intangible invisible objects out there
that you cannot touch
or see that are mediating all the
transactions that mother nature runs
daily
no one ever defined the word exist
that's why atheists
theists and agnostics go around in
circles and i used to be an atheist so
you know i i kind of slapped myself i i
didn't figure this out until later
that atheism is the religion of
mathematics all these mathematicians
they say oh i'm an atheist i don't
believe in god you know
you're not going to believe even god in
the 21st century
now i believe in space time and i
believe in big bang and you know
creationism and i believe in all this
nonsense that was shut down my throat
in my quest for my phd that's what they
believe in
so they come up with all this nonsense
why because they don't follow the
correct
scientific method and what fails with
atheism
is the scientific method in science
in physics we do not say i believe in
god
in science we do not say i don't believe
in god
in science we do not say i don't know if
god exists or not i think i'm going to
run an experiment to find out if god
exists or not
and still you know i also doubted
whether god exists or not
no none of that belongs to science in
science we say
let us assume that god exists
because god can only be an assumption a
hypothesis and a hypothesis is not a
theory
hypothesis are the objects and the
definitions you present at the beginning
of your theory then you can explain what
god did you can say this how he created
the universe
fine you can talk about anything you
want but first you got to present god
and you don't say i believe in god you
say let us assume
god exists and for sure you don't say
like some of these
people who insist that observation is
part of the scientific method and say
i observed god oh you observed god
yeah i saw the flower though so
beautiful and the bee running around
and i said only god could have made that
well did you observe god or did you
observe a bee
so that's the issue you know what did
you observe so no observation is not
part of the scientific method science we
do not observe
science we sit back and try to visualize
what could mother nature be using in
that invisible intangible
world that you cannot observe or touch
okay so that's the way it works and so
that's why a lot of these people
don't understand why observation is not
part of the scientific method
it's part of the religious method that
all these other people do why because
they do
research they don't do science they do
research
research is not science the fact that
you did research and studied
and did experiments doesn't mean you can
explain okay
so no the so-called scientific method
we've had the last 400 years
is not a scientific method it's a method
of religion it should not be confused
for science
at all and that's why they ended up with
all this irrational
these irrational explanations anyways um
i pro no one ever proposed physical
interconnectedness
that's that's mine sorry uh once it's
discovered once you discover fire no one
can discover it again
okay uh nobody proposed a rope-like
mediator for light a physical mediator
and no one discovered a mechanism of
action at a distance how to produce
pull you don't have pulling all of
mathematical physics
and i don't know this guy's going to
talk about gravity
if he gets that far and and
so how does he kind of produce pool
without a physical mediator
as soon as he puts a phys physical
mediator he's going to have to
you know give credit to bill gatey he's
going to have to
go to why god doesn't exist to get that
information to get you know how
you know one atom pulls on another with
the
fabric of what of existence
uh no one ever discovered the
overturning of the pyramid extinction
mechanisms the population pyramid
overturn and the ecological pyramid
overturned
now when discovered that humans will
soon become extinct because
our whole economic system will collapse
very soon in fact one of the reasons i
don't care about money because
you know i'm not going to take you to my
tomb i don't want to be the richest guy
in the cemetery
[Laughter]
no one ever discovered the definition of
life okay
that's that's here that's in this book
okay
and it's also my other book in the
neanderthal book it's also there as well
i discussed that as well
anyways until white god doesn't exist
which was published in 1998
okay everyone did physics with one-way
particles
and one-way waves for the first time
everyone for the first time we have
interconnectedness physical
interconnectedness that means that you
have a physical entity that which has
shape
but you cannot touch or see it which is
the wrong definition of the word object
and that's why it was important to
define the word object
and then until 1998 until my book
everyone did physics by moving concepts
around and they still do
in fact this fellow talks about what the
fabric of existence
as a love the fabric of existence you
know it's a way of
eluding the question that's what this uh
mathematical physicist did he went in
there and said ask him
what is between the electro and the
protein says a fabric factory
what what is a fabric what the hell is a
fabric
yeah that's what they do they elude the
question by putting these words they
think they answer the question
but here's the epilogue okay and um
and refers mainly i think to his frau
this nasty girl okay and
she puts in her uh in her sight that
demystifying science site
what is life and says uh
well she goes through all this rigmarole
mentioning a fellow known as thomas gold
and this is what she studies i guess she
follows or
thinks that this guy knew something
about something and
in the end she says you know what is
that we don't know what life is
we'll continue investigating for the
next 2 000 years
to find out what life is well all i can
tell her is uh
she should go and visit the fat fists
hub pages site
uh and fatfist you know he got that from
why god doesn't exist
and he tells you what the definition of
life is
here you have these phds they're all
biology they claimed
their biologists because they warmed up
seat at the university for 10 or so
years
and they said i'm a biologist or why are
you a biologist
well because i got a phd well
you know william lane craig he's got a
phd in divinity studies
what kind of phd is that that's garbage
you know i clean my nose with that
you know he might think oh i'm a doctor
doctor in what doctor
god and the belief in god is that what
his phd is in
it's worthless garbage and if if you
don't know
what life is and biology is the study of
life
then you're not a biologist i don't care
how many years you warmed a seed
in college okay it's just as simple as
that straight forward
no no run around and here these people
claim to be
biologists doctors because they have a
phd
and they don't know what life is they're
chills trying to find the definition of
life
and they'll be looking for it forever
because i mean we had biology what
maybe 200 years now at least even more i
mean
you could go all the way to robert hook
who did micrograffia in 1665 he looked
through the microscope started looking
at these
little things that were moving around in
there
and so you know how many more years do
you need to define the word life
and until you do you're not a biologist
because a biologist is the guy who
studies life and you don't know what
you're studying
you know so this is the issue the issue
all these people
they they have these phds they don't
know what they're talking about just
like the mathematical
physicist they think they're talking
about something and they give you the
most ridiculous explanation that you
they can find they say a particle can be
in two places at once
so why did the guy warm a seed for 10
years at a university to tell you the
particle can be at two places at once
and then when you say well that sounds
irrational well yeah that's not
important
you're not supposed to take it literally
that's the kind of answer you get
and you wouldn't have that computer if
quantum weren't right and
that kind of thing you know those are
the answers you get
uh yeah and they run and they run the
world of science
so yeah all i can ask uh nasty there
is uh for her to check um not not to
look at tom gold he didn't know
squad about anything even about physics
i mean he was a supposedly a
uh physicist uh he he went around with
uh
what was his name fred hoyle
who came up with a steady state theory
and they didn't know squad it was just
as dumb as all the other
mathematical physicists out there they
were all
you know cuckoo in the head because all
they have is our irrational explanation
and this lady follows this guy and says
oh thomas gold
you know he came up with all these great
ideas about temperature and who knows
what
he's not a scientist not a scientist at
all because he doesn't follow the
scientific method
okay he doesn't know how to define words
and no mathematician out there has ever
learned
how to define words or realize that you
have to define words as yet as the first
step of the scientific method
that's where all these people fail okay
anyways
uh that's uh the story there
you know a little more about plagiarism
now hopefully
let me um get into some of the questions
some of the
comments people made on first on
extinction
okay not too many questions today
because i was busy looking up this
this this couple this couple from oregon
okay it says uh if money disappears
all of the food disappears at the same
time because food
is money no way
you can't because see when whenever you
see this this is the difference between
a city
uh born person and a guy who was born in
the jungle
person who was born in a jungle or an
animal that was born in the jungle
he doesn't trade food one thing you
don't trade is food
and people don't understand that today
they have a hard time understanding what
do you mean i don't trade food you know
if i like bananas and the other guy
likes apples
and i have an apple he's got a banana
well then i'll give him my apple and he
gives me banana it's straightforward
both we it's win-win we both win
that's the way this is the mentality of
these people
this is the mentality this is what
they've been brainwashed with and so you
can't tell him look
you're not gonna give him your apple
you're gonna
kill him and steal his banana that's the
way a lion works out there
a lion doesn't go with the uh i don't
know where the uh
hyena and say oh oh oh you've got deer
and and i've got uh this little gazelle
uh i i would rather trade my
your trade you you know my gazelle for
your deer because the deer is a little
bigger and
and you like gazelles don't you i mean
there's they taste
better and so they do a trade-off
no no it's not the way it works believe
me that's not the way it works the
lion's gonna try to kill the
hyena and get him out of there he's
gonna take both he's gonna take the deer
and the gazelle if he can
that's the way it works out there and
when we were hunter gatherers you know
for most of our existence ninety percent
of our existence
we didn't trade and how do you get that
through people today in a world
that everything relies on trade they
don't know anything else
and then when you say look someday we
won't have trade because someday we
in the past we did not have trade they
don't understand that
they say no we always had trade we
traded uh what seashells for
uh mammoth that's what these people have
this is what these people believe no you
don't trade food when food is the only
thing of value
you don't trade food animals in the wild
they all understand that
unfortunately all these people who think
they're intelligent because they're
humans
i doubt some of them are human but uh
you know they they don't understand that
and it's it's
something that they lost that intuition
over there we've been so brainwashed by
trade that people believe
that we can't live without trade we will
never
live without trade because it's in our
self-interest
this is the way they see it they don't
realize that food is a little more
self-interest than trade
but they don't understand that how do
you get that through their heads
okay here's another one what does he say
he says and
if the economy collapses the military
will blah blah blah blah blah blah
no the military won't there won't be any
military because
when the economy not if but when the
economy collapses it's guaranteed the
economy is going to fall apart
when the economy collapses not because
i'm predicting
like some people say i'm not predicting
anything that's not a prediction
okay so try to understand i went to the
future
i went i'm looking back at how humans
died
and found out that they died because
money disappeared
the economy fell apart why because all
other animals also they had their
extinction happen when their economies
disappeared
that's the mechanism it's got nothing to
do with predicting but people don't
understand that because
well you're talking about the future
aren't you yeah no i'm talking about the
past i'm explaining a mechanism but they
don't understand that either
okay anyways if the economy collapses
the military will no the military
won't and the reason is there won't be
any military
the worst thing that the rich people can
do is say oh i'm going to grab
all these fellas that work for me and
we're going to go in the tunnel
we're gonna go underground and we're
gonna have all this food
and these guys are gonna continue being
my servants
will they i think the first thing
they're gonna do is kill the old guy
who's rich
and they're gonna keep the food because
that's what's going to keep them alive
maybe they're going to kill each other
as well until one guy survives and
that's the guy who stays with the with a
booty
that's what's going to happen now there
won't be any police there won't be any
courts there won't be any military when
the
global economy collapses a soldier has
no allegiance to anything not even
country
and those who do well you know they're
mistaken
and mistake cost you your life now you
got to fight for your own salvation
there maybe your family or whatever
whatever is dear to you so you're going
to use that gun for something else
you're not going to use it to put order
out there in the streets
you're going to use it to rob just like
the
soldiers in the soviet revolution you
know
1917 they went out there and they uh
they used the guns not to kill people
they went in there to
get their share of um
of goods that's how it happened
okay my grandmother went through that
interesting
okay you know she uh she met uh
trotsky told me about she used to be a
communist too until she
got out of it then she tried to get me
out of communism she couldn't do it
until i got out of it myself
and she was right i was wrong
okay fella says changing subject here
when we view a magnetic field using
feral cells
or the use of a crt television screen we
will see
no motion in the field ah
the iron filings are in motion in the
demonstrations he is showing which is
the one i'm showing at the bottom okay
the iron filings you can see they're
moving towards
the magnet in slow motion you can see
you know um this time delayed
thing you can see how they're moving
little by little towards the magnet
something is pulling them there you
could say something's pushing them there
okay alex even accept that no problem
something is coming in contact with each
iron filing and
taking it closer to the magnet that is
what we're saying
that's the observation right
that would everybody wants observation
well there you have your observation
okay now did you observe
what came in contact with the iron
filing that's the question
and you can't say the magnetic field
because the magnetic field is all of it
which you can't see either right i mean
if you observe the magnetic field i want
you to draw it for me what is the
magnetic field
okay and all you can draw is a bunch of
iron filings say well this is
with the pattern left by the iron
filings you still haven't drawn the
magnetic field
you draw what you drew is a bunch of
iron filings i want you to draw the
magnetic field what is this
so-called magnetic field but you got to
identify what came in contact with each
one of the iron filings i don't want you
talking about a field i want you to talk
about
one iron filing i hope that's clear i
mean i don't know how else
to say that we didn't observe that the
magnetic field is in motion
we observed the our filings in motion
he says he did not observe the magnetic
field in motion
i wonder why well here's the why okay
well field is a concept it's a bunch of
numbers
and you saw what's his name nick lucid
and he already told you about that the
other day i i mentioned him you know
what the heck are fields and what he put
a bunch of numbers
that's a magnetic field bunch of numbers
and if it's a bunch of numbers it's a
concept and if it's a concept yeah
concepts don't move so you discovered
for the first time in your life that
concepts don't move
okay it reinforces the notion that
observation is not part of the
scientific method because this guy says
he observed iron filings in motion and
that didn't help him at all
because he doesn't understand the
question he doesn't understand what he's
got to
look for what what the what he's got to
answer what he's got to answer is what
came in contact with
each individual one of those tiny iron
files what pulled it what pushed it
what came in contact with the skin of
the art valleys that's the question
and hopefully it's not a field which
which is what covers the whole magnet
so you can't say the field came in
contact with it especially because a
field is a
bunch of numbers and you know a bunch of
numbers is a concept and concepts don't
move
so he can't use the word field to
explain that
okay faraday and uh maxwell both said
okay that there is matter in motion
inside a region they called magnetic
field so you have to identify that
matter that is in motion inside
the magnetic field and you can't say
charged particle like he says there the
charged particle in a magnetic field
there's no physical object called
charged
charge is a number means 1.6 times 10 to
the
minus 19 coulombs that's what charge
means
okay it charges a number okay
and then you can't use positive or
negative because that's not a physical
interpretation what does positive mean
what does negative mean
in physical terms and uh yeah you can
ask um
uh what's his name uh shiloh
or nasty they'll they'll tell you
because uh you know they took it out of
my book they say it's clockwise and
counterclockwise that's what it is
of whatever you know the uh fabric of
existence i guess
and so what you have to answer that
question there the last one what
physical object compelled the iron
piling to move until you can
draw the physical object now until you
can tell me what physical object
moved came in contact with the iron
filing to move it
uh you know you can roll around in
circles forever
okay and so yeah that's the question you
got to answer so i don't know if you're
ever going to answer that question uh
the only way to answer it is uh upload a
drawing or
or a link to a drawing so that or a
picture or whatever
some image we want to see what came in
contact with the arm family just
take a snapshot of that or you know
draw it illustrate it put a link to it
and then we'll know
what physical object came in contact
with one i'm filing okay
okay and uh same fellow i think here um
again not too many questions today i was
busy with something else
investigating this gentleman
and says take one magnet and measure the
magnetic field
strength okay i don't know why i have to
measure the strength but let's continue
now clap your hands okay clap my hands
good and use your voice within a few
feet
the needle will not move okay
good now put one magnet on one side of
the meter and the second one
and the other facing each other in
attraction
measure the magnetic field strength i
don't know why okay i'll
measure that's what he wants me to do
i'll measure the needle doesn't move
okay however if you clap your hands
or do different tones with your voice
the needle moves in different amounts of
different tones
we have just put a magnetic field in
motion
uh no what we put is a needle in motion
okay so here's the million dollar
question what physical
object came in contact with a needle and
compelled it to move
everywhere he says the needle will not
move the needle will move
he's talking about a needle where did he
get the fact that the magnetic
field moved what is a field we just saw
what a magnetic field is what was it a
bunch of numbers
okay so you can't say that the field
move
okay and uh so what is a field let's
find out because this fellow thinks a
field is a physical object that moves
first he said it doesn't move now he
says it does move there's a field for
you a bunch of numbers that are
vibrating that are moving
that's what a field is a field is just a
bunch of numbers and what they say
when they say that the field vibrates
the field moves what they're moving is a
bunch of numbers
okay this this is the notion
mathematical physics has this is the
explanation they have
and of course it's a ridiculous uh
irrational explanation that everybody
learns by wrote in college or high
school okay
and so here are the definitions of
fields and again that shows you that
it's not a physical object because if
you can define it it's not an
object objects we point to a name we
draw we
have an image in front of us and you
don't have to define it
but they define a field they say it's
what a region of space
that's out of the dictionary.com and
another one that you'll find in
wikipedia a physical quantity
i don't know about physical there's no
such thing as a physical quantity
i don't know on number five that is
physical okay physical means it has
shape that it has
um you know that it's an object and a
five is a number it's accounting
that's all it is and so a quantity is
not a physical object neither is a
number
and so if a field is a number or a
region neither one qualifies as a
physical object
you cannot say that a field moves okay
and i like the one at the stack exchange
they have a they try to answer as best
as possible i mean
these are all phds so they have no clue
about anything okay
it says a field is a function that
returns a value for a point in space
fields are not matter and i consider
substance an unfortunate word to use in
a definition
yeah because they never define the word
substance and mathematicians are not
concerned with substances
they're concerned with numbers and
equations but he says
but they are part of the universe and
they are part of physics
well if it's a number how can it be part
of physics is physics deals with
physical
objects what they are is the aggregate
effect
that's what it is effect of the exchange
of virtual particles
and what are virtual particles numbers
so we have virtual numbers that pop in
from the void
governed by quantum field theory in the
case of
electromagnetism or the effect of the
curvature of space time in the case of
gravity
now it is very easy to get hung up on
this
is it real or not is it a real or not
thing
and most people do for at least a while
but please just put it aside
yeah they don't want to talk about
existence because they never defined a
word or have
any idea what existence means
it says when you peer really hard into
the depth of the theory it turns out
that it is hard to say for sure
that stuff is stuff and i like the final
comment there the lion says and round
and round we go yeah
no doubt it looks like we're going round
and round circles
and that's from the stack exchange and
they will not allow you to put anything
in there you you can only put in there
if you are
you know masters degree and above and if
you
uh subscribe to the mathematical method
which they call the scientific method
and if you put equation then they'll
allow you in there but if you go in
there and uh
you know talk about qualitative stuff
like you know what is a field
they said it's a relevant question we
don't care about that
and we don't know if it exists because
we don't know what a substance is we
don't care about that
so how can they talk about fields if
they're going to say that a field moves
a charge or moves an iron filing
if they're not going to define or talk
qualitatively about what a field is
so yeah field is not a physical object
and that's the problem with this fellow
he thinks that a field is a physical
object he says well the field moved it
or like if he said it first the field
doesn't move yeah field doesn't move
because it's a concept and if a field
moves
oh man you better go see a doctor or
maybe you should
lay off the booze because it means
you've overdone it
okay another issue here
father says let assume that only
consciousness exists and that all
objects are concepts
so my answer is let's assume instead
that you are going to define
object in concept so that we can
understand what you're talking about
and you can always check with shiloh and
nasty and they'll put you up to date on
what
an object and a concept are so you visit
their site
they must define plagiarism okay
okay here's another um comment
question phases oh yeah
the model of the atom is nothing more
than a concept for visualization he says
it's the flow of energy involved with
mass oscillation
the illusion of space is empty
uh the densities are creating that okay
not connected to time
he says that you know space is not
connected to time
um but einstein showed that space
is something connected to time he showed
it you know observation
through observation you know uh and the
real force
of gravity etc etc an atom is a period
of time connected
to the speed of light a wave in
oscillation
my poor god poor people really you got
to pity them
uh mother nature was not kind to
their brain and they think they're
smarter than the animals
that that's the worst part and he
continues i'm not going to read all of
this because too long
about underlying a few things what this
guy thinks science is he says mechanical
think
mechanical things we build work better
so that's technology
it talks about knowledge has nothing to
do with science
it talks about measurement talks about
shown in other words
observation talks about measurement
talks about confirmation
you know confirmed to whom to the pope
talks about certainty
by whom who's certain of it is it you is
it the pope who's certain about it the
dalai lama
uh confirmed time has a symmetry
confirmed to whom
and again all these things observe
confirming and
all this stuff what is it all about it's
about descriptions he's saying we went
into the
lab we measured and this is what we came
up with
none of these are theories none of these
are explanations
of phenomena none of these tell us or
give us even a hint of what an atom
looks like
what gravity is what magnetism is
none of it descriptions will not help us
we need to sit back
and visualize how mother nature could be
doing her magic
that's the only way there is no other
way to deal with
intangible invisible entities
there's an entity that which you can
touch and see no it's that which has
shaped the only universal property of
all objects okay
and a final issue here final question
i wasn't going to deal with this one but
later on i thought better and i said
well no this
this has to be addressed at first i was
going to brush it aside
run you know slap myself uh is a helix
parallel to
its axis it's equidistant after all
and yeah he's right uh equidistant but
we gotta find out what we're talking
about okay first of all
you know we have think of it as a coil
okay here here
you see it as a uh itinerary think of it
as a coil
it's a little we'll talk about a perfect
coal coil you know it coils around
in a perfect circle let's assume right
now coiling
upwards right and it's got an imaginary
axis okay but you can put a stick in
there if you want
okay and the question that he's asking
is you have equidistant
uh you know the distance between the
coil
and the axis everywhere
is the same so is are
is a coil parallel to the
axis well again the problem here is the
following
the only way you can deal with this is
by using tangents okay you go in there
you put a tangent at a given location
on the coil a tangent on a given
location on the stick
okay and those two tangents
are parallel as soon as you move a
little bit now you have to look at those
two
those two are tangent but you can
because you don't have a straight line
you cannot
you know you cannot use a straight line
notion of parallel you have to use the
curved notion and that's equidistant
anyways
it doesn't matter it doesn't change
anything every point
to use that term every location along
that curve
has to be looked at through a tangent
so you're only comparing two locations
and drawing an imaginary tangent those
two tangents
are what are parallel okay and that's uh
even true for the notion we have today
of geometry which is you know
parallel lines even though they're
curved they're still parallel as long as
they don't meet
that's that's their notion and yeah as
long as they don't meet
uh for sure they're not tangent but
the definition is wrong or irrational
because you got to go to all the way to
infinity
to find out if they meet or not and good
luck with that you know i hope you
come back someday because you can't come
back until you went all the way to
infinity
right wherever that is uh heaven and uh
find out if they meet or not
so yeah it's uh it's not a definition
it's a proof
say run an experiment go to infinity and
find out these lines meet that's what
the definition of today says
okay with that i'll see you on wednesday
and i'll
answer some of the questions that i did
not answer today
just too much work okay so we'll see on
wednesday